The Tiny Nation of
Sealand
Pirate radio, kidnapping, battles- the principality
of Sealand has seen all of these things and
more, despite only being a tiny micronation
lying about 7 nautical miles the coast from
Suffolk, England.
If you haven’t heard of Sealand before,
it is the site of one of Britain’s Maunsell
Naval Sea Forts that were utilized during
WWII.
This particular one was originally named HM
Fort Roughs.
The fort’s primary function was to keep
tabs on the Germans who were laying mines
off the coast of England at the time.
The structure itself was built on top of barge,
which was then towed out to the present day
location and sunk.
Within about 30 minutes of the barge settling
on the ocean floor, the crew of about 100
soldiers had it up and running.
(The fort itself can accommodate up to about
300 people.)
It remained in operation after the war for
a time, but was abandoned by the Royal Navy
in 1956.
It was left unattended for another 11 years
before pirate radio broadcasters decided that
it would make a perfect base of operations
due to being situated in international waters.
However, in the same year, a competing broadcaster
by the name of Roy Bates, broadcaster of the
illegal station “Radio Essex” aka “Britain’s
Better Music Station,” was caught by authorities
and ultimately needed a new location for his
pirate station.
What better place for a pirate radio station
than at sea in international waters.
Thus, he decided he wanted the fort for himself.
Using his military training- he was a Major
in the British Army during the war- he managed
to evict the squatters…before becoming one
himself, along with his fifteen year old son,
Michael who aided in the fight to take over
the fort.
Bates never did utilise the fort for a radio
station though.
Shortly after his hostile takeover, it became
illegal under British law, via the Marine
Broadcasting Offences Act, to broadcast pirate
radio, even outside a 3 mile radius of the
coastline.
Previously, this was perfectly legal outside
of that span.
As a result, Bates did what any rational being
would – he declared his oceanic fort an
independent sovereignty and renamed it Sealand.
Oddly, this was a perfectly legal move, thanks
to a loophole in the law that Bates’ attorney
found.
Specifically, because the structure was not
only in international waters, but also had
been abandoned by the UK, it was legally up
for grabs to anyone who wanted it.
The UK military did for a time consider re-taking
the fort, but decided if the Bates family
pressed them during the invasion- perhaps
firing on the military- and they were then
forced to kill the family, it wouldn’t make
for good press; so they abandoned the idea.
They did, however, destroy another of the
forts that was still in existence to avoid
any copycats.
There was also an issue in 1968 where Michael
fired on a group of engineers that were working
on some buoys near Sealand.
At one point, they started making catcalls
up at Michael’s sister, Penny, and shouting
various lewd remarks.
Prince Michael didn’t take kindly to the
Princess of Sealand being spoken to in such
an uncivilised manner, so fired several warning
shots to shut them up.
It worked, but he was arrested once he returned
to the mainland.
However, because the event took place in international
waters and the platform, according to the
court, was no longer under British jurisdiction,
they let him off scot-free.
This was a landmark ruling as now the British
court system had officially declared the fort
free from British rule.
With the court’s 1968 ruling, by 1975, Bates
was doing his best to prove that he was serious
about Sealand being a country.
At the encouragement of his wife, Joan, he
wrote a constitution, designed a flag, wrote
a national anthem, invented a unit of currency
and even had postage stamps made up.
In the following years, he would also add
passports to that list, which to this day
you can purchase.
During this time, he was approached by a myriad
individuals and organisations wishing to use
Sealand’s location for their own gain.
Bates turned them all away, at least until
1978.
A group of self proclaimed diamond merchants
from the Netherlands and Germany asked Bates
and his wife to join them in Austria so they
could discuss a business proposition.
Everything seemed to be legitimate until the
meeting time came and went without the group
showing up.
Concerned, Bates attempted to make contact
with Michael via phoning some fisherman, but
learned from these fisherman that a helicopter
had been spotted over the ‘country’.
It turns out, the fort had been taken and
Prince Michael had been locked in a cell without
any food or water, before being deposited
in the Netherlands with no ID or money.
The invaders were a group led by the self-proclaimed
Prime Minister of Sealand, German lawyer Alexander
Achenbach, who had hired Dutch, Austrian,
and German mercenaries to aid him in taking
over the fort.
Bates wasn’t going to give up his country
so easily, though according to Michael was
furious that his son had let the helicopter
land.
The Fort itself is actually reasonably hard
to invade given that there are no ladders
or any such method of scaling from below,
and the only other way to invade is via helicopter,
which is easily fended off with rifles, assuming
you aren’t being fired on yourself, which
Michael wasn’t.
Once reunited with his son, Bates and Michael
armed themselves and enlisted the aid of a
helicopter pilot who had worked on the James
Bond franchise, which is very fitting here.
According to Michael, they approached the
fort into the wind, to mask the sound of the
helicopter, and chose dawn to strike when
the invaders were likely to be groggy or still
asleep, but there was still enough light to
attack by.
Michael and his father slid down ropes that
were suspended from the helicopter, the former
armed with a sawed-off shotgun and the latter
with a pistol.
The usurpers emerged from the fort to see
what was going on.
While many reports say Michael fired a warning
shot at them, which scared the invaders out
of their wits (no doubt also because of the
action hero-like entrance), Michael doesn’t
claim such.
He said in an interview that when he landed,
he dropped his gun and when the butt hit the
deck, the gun went off, nearly causing himself
to be shot in the process.
Nevertheless, when the invaders saw the princes
of Sealand had returned armed, they surrendered
immediately and were subsequently tried and
found guilty of treason, then held as POW’s
until their home countries could negotiate
their release.
The price of this release was set at about
the equivalent of $35,000 in Deutsche Marks,
or about $125,000 today.
Those nations appealed to the UK to intervene
to get their citizens back, but the UK government
declined to step in, citing the 1968 court
decision concerning Michael’s shooting at
the engineers where the court had declared
the fort independent of the UK.
Thus, they were absolved of any responsibility
or obligation in the matter.
This was a double-win for the Bates family,
as once again the UK government seemed to
be supporting their claim of sovereignty.
Germany then sent one of their diplomats to
negotiate the release of the POWs.
This also bolstered the Bates family’s claim
that Sealand was an independent nation, or
so the family stated, as Germany had now undergone
diplomatic relations with the micronation.
After a couple weeks of negotiation, the Bates
family let the invaders go.
However, once back home, the ousted Prime
Minister of Sealand, Achenbach, setup the
Sealand Rebel Government, as a “government
in exile” and the true rulers of Sealand.
No one else bothered to try and utilise the
country again until the Falklands War in 1982.
Some Argentineans asked Bates to sell Sealand
to them due to its proximity to England.
He respectfully declined.
These days, Sealand generates income by offering
titles to regular Joes like you and me.
For a mere £29.99 you can become a Lord or
Lady of Sealand.
Or, if you’ve got extra cash to blow, you
can shell out £199.99 and become a Count
or Countess of the micronation.
The future of Sealand is somewhat ambiguous
at the present time.
Prince Roy (I don’t know why he didn’t
go straight for King Roy) passed away in 2012,
leaving Prince Michael as his heir, himself
up there in years at 62, though he does have
two heirs- Liam and James Bates.
As for the years ahead, there has been talk
of expansion and the possibility of opening
a casino or resort on site.
Bonus Facts:
• In 2008, representatives of Sealand won
the world egg throwing championship.
Sealand participates in various sporting events,
often with athletes from various nations volunteering
to represent the nation.
• In 2007, the popular torrent site, The
Pirate Bay, attempted to purchase Sealand,
but were turned away.
The Bates family are loath to allow anything
so controversial to exist on the fort, for
fear the UK may decide to re-take it after
all these years.
That said, in 2000, Sealand became home to
HavenCo – a data hosting services company
with Michael Bates listed as one of the directors
of the company.
The company later ceased to be in 2008, but
in 2013 was resurrected.
• The official motto of the Principality
of Sealand is “E Mare Libertas,” – “From
the Sea, Freedom”.